beaucoup de choses à changer parce que
c'est pas la même période qu'on vivait
quand on était enfant parce que quand
j'étais enfant il y avait la mer on
avait la plage qui ont joué au football
toute cette allée là c'était la plage un
la page arrivait jusqu'à après le canot
qui vous voyez là après le canot il y
avait encore même un peu apprécié cup
est encore lucas no 1
c'était bien il y avait deux quais là
c'est parti les parties excusons les
quais sont partis et tout est parti ils
ont pris la maison ils n'ont plus de
maison sont retirés les lettrines qui
était là il y avait des machins qu'on
avait fait des expositions qu'on avait
fait tout pour que les touristes
puissent venir
il n'y a rien du tout tout est parti par
la mer maintenant c'est pas c'est pas le
prêcheur encore la pression s'est passé
parce que fini parce que maintenant on
essaie de reloger les gens mais c'est
pas encore ça
or le les gens et les gens ils avaient
le capital ils ont peut être de capital
les pays arabes où ils vont payer un
engagement va on lui donne en ligue ou
des horloges mais roger c'est pas comme
ça si on leur donne la maison à la
personne c'est pas faire payer des
loyers mais c'est ça on a cassé quartier
cimetière jamais ça mais qui est délabré
a causé à cause de la mer à cause de la
mer tout ça c'est